first funerals for the 22 shooting
victims in El Paso will be held today
yesterday President Trump visited that
city and Dayton Ohio or another gunman
killed nine people last weekend the
president met was met in both cities by
protesters and supporters Ben Tracy is
at the White House Ben what did the
president do on his trip
well good morning the president met with
victims of the shooting he met with law
enforcement and first responders and the
people that he met with really did seem
to appreciate his visit but there were
also protests nearly everywhere the
president went and that seemed to bother
mr. Trump President Trump returned to
Washington Wednesday night defending his
reception tweeting the love and respect
and enthusiasm were there for all to see
he made back-to-back visits to the two
cities rocked by mass shootings but not
everyone viewed the trips as he'll
basically play the part of him being a
sympathizer when in reality it's been in
his rallies that he has painted us as an
unsafe City if we got targets from El
Paso where the alleged shooter targeted
Hispanics was especially divided both
sides are using some strong rhetoric
congresswoman Veronica Escobar said the
president's words have hurt her
community I felt it was important that
we come together and not focus on the
visitor but focus on El Paso at his stop
in Dayton where nine people were killed
Sunday the White House did not allow
reporters or cameras into the hospital
despite originally planning to do so we
left Ohio and the love the respect who
were the office
it was I wish you could have been in
there to see it oh he was comforting he
did the right thing
Ohio senator sherrod Brown in Dayton
mayor nan Willie said the president's
visit was appreciated but his normal
rhetoric is not a lot of the time his
talk can be very divisive and that's the
last thing we need a date with you
despite that some in Dayton saw mr.
Trump's trip as his presidential duty
he's supporting the people and the
families that had a loss it wouldn't
have been humane for him to come now the
White House did not allow journalists
traveling with the president inside the
hospital and that's because the White
House said this was not meant to be a
photo op but then the White House and
the president tweeted out photos of the
president's visit as well as a video
edited with music Dana Ben thank you